I will bring you well as I will dedicate you also
here the wind of
Norway how is the weather there coldness you
ask for ifphone but not tarch like a
bonus highlights the bow but today in
fact I have the title to ask you but as
usual to ask a few
questions that interest not only
me but most of those  people who
learn foreign languages
yes that you speak at least 10
languages
yes tell me right
you have some unique
abilities or something you
do such a special secret for this
what is your secret of learning I think that I
do not have a huge talent learning
languages ​​I think that most people
can learn a language without problems I think
that I have a method of effective methods
and because therefore I can not succeed
and more often a lot of languages ​​I know how
to learn languages ​​and I think that this is
very very important because  if,
in principle, in general, knowing in this way
to learn languages ​​​​and at all possible, this is very
very very important, but you learn languages
on your own to as far as I know all the
languages ​​you learned on your own and you
use the traditional method or
here is yours no yes your own method
my own
development they call no hand
understandable yes and in
what way how no I learned I
can clearly 10 languages ​​at least one secret
open it
especially at the beginning it's easy to translate
i'm translating from a language to another this
means for example if i'm learning russian i'm
here i started to learn russian
i used my native language it lie down
and by means of translation i can't
understand you understand the language and this one
something  what I did at the beginning, then I
just communicate with people
and watch a movie, and so on, I think that a
very delicate phase of
learning languages ​​was started because I
think that most people simply do not
know how to start learning languages
and I use here I translate for example  from
italian to russian
i then from russian to this and this is a very
wick that everyone can use
for that  in order to learn effectively a
language is there anything at all in a
language other than that it is very interesting very simple and
very interesting and as it turned out to be very
effective it seems to me that
one of the most popular questions on this is
how to learn new words most
effectively some of your
learning recipes  new words, I think that a
lot of people make a
huge mistake, so they think that the
method itself in order to study sara is
just memorize them as I said by
means of translation I can just study
and in the future it is very important, for example
, to
write down words in principle, and so on and especially
learn words from context for example
i cant just memorize layer down conte
coin price in order to learn new
words and i think context is very very
important of course in order to search
through thread or now all sorts of things and i
think people should just learn
how to search more interesting  cx te vi
burn and and this too of course I can't
talk about the details now I'm thinking  yu that
we need to learn how our brain
works, the brain works and we know it,
we can of course study more
like what are your first steps in learning a
new language for a glass you just chose
today I will learn for example
Polish what are the first three but not  I will betray what
first steps you take the text I also know
what else I think it all depends
on what phase you are in, for example,
at the beginning, as I said, I don’t translate, I
translate from one language to another, and
then
I don’t think that, in principle, cooperation is
very important  this means communicating with people is
very important and me using skype in order
to just communicate with people and of course
write down mistakes
detention so on I would like to clarify
further once about the first step I
understood correctly, that is, even if
you don’t know the language at all, you
still try right away  translate from it to the
very beginning, then I use the intellect with a
penny
to make the Internet
so that it is very good when you cook
like poetry  so I thought that if you want to
use of course you can use
skype because almost everyone has problems and the bottom of the
computer is because people do not
know how to learn I
use skype
while it is very important especially for
learning languages ​​how to do
things this is very help and  very important
plays a big big video and what
are the three most important things in
learning a foreign language here are three things
that you need to know there that you need
to do it is necessary to address because it
plays a big role in the language or from ours
it means to say that most people
are afraid to say questions for example they are afraid to admit
mistakes
because there are methods
if books will be easier in general
life of course because they
talk a lot about the country because you don’t
work, we all can look for time
to study
big because in order to
study languages ​​and every
opportunity in life there are people because  what to
use necessarily  it’s even
if you live that it’s especially [ __ ] up they
say that it’s simply impossible to speak to
someone’s face because they don’t live in the
astral plane there are not
foreigners then it’s not true especially on the
Internet of course it’s good to
use it and you communicate with people
to achieve a good result of course
you need to know how  in this way and in this
way how to communicate via skype look for
people nice people with whom a person
makes mistakes normal person admits they are good thanks a huge
bow amazing for the interview and i think
it will be useful for a lot of people thank you very much and see you